davos luca herzlich willkommen meine
lieben zuschauer hier heute zu einer
weiteren episode mit der optimismus also
meiner virtual reality brille und zwar
spielen wir heute mit dieser brille das
spielen startet ok ich habe jetzt den
job aussuchen ich nehme jetzt einfach
mal diese gummis chef diskette und packt
ich im moment kitchen du hast ja also
das jetzt meine küche schon ich habe
hier ganz ganz viele preise bekommen wie
beispielsweise den studienort wunsch
dass jetzt ein feuerlöscher er den cut
nicht nehmen und kann mit dem haben
kleiner pisser bevor es mit salz und
pfeffer
das kann ich auch mal nehmen und kann
das ranking hengstberger high end
technik also ich sollte bacon und ein
spiegelei machen hier auf dem grill
läuft schon super hier die man diese
hose herunter die ist schon fertig die
könnt ihr gerne essen
leute die aber real topf müssen jemanden
aber ich glaube dass hierfür ein
kühlschrank hh als letzte scheiß egal
wenn das ding da anbrennen ich brauche
auf jeden fall den bacon den klatsch
auch hier drauf was guckst du traurig
also das becken ist grün geworden das
heißt ich neben den jetzt mal hier und
flaschen auf den teller vom hunger ab
jetzt die kacke sind dass die eier
alltag
also wenn ihr jetzt das spiegelei und da
seid ihr hallo also das hier ist glaube
ich unser blender
nee das ist das ist eine teekanne idee
kann auch oder was ja klar logisch meine
küche aufgebaut also sollen jetzt
irgendwelche von unseren früchten
reinpacken das heißt ich nehme mal ich
nehme mal die hier vorne eine davon und
bestellen scheiße jetzt einfach jemand
an stellen kann
mach doch die stelle ich ihnen und da
kommt jetzt weg und die zeit kann hier
und da daimler und appetit er wird mit
liebe zubereitet yukos und im team
komplett mit dir du hier schön was da
drin das heißt wir nehmen jetzt das ding
stellen es hier drauf damit das ganze
ein bisschen erhitzt wird und das kommt
dann gleich da in unserem job kein plan
welcher typ sich so eine dumme tasse
kauft also los geht die party hier den
teebeutel rein jetzt nehmen wir das ding
muss sagen dass die dinge ja fertig da
guck dich so dass wenn ich jetzt sind
einfach deinen charakter alter assistent
mehr kann ich essen
s
ist so eine scheiße aha ok oh mein gott
ich freue mich hier soll den muss ich
hier in den toaster rein
kannst du einfach anhand deine fresse
halten und jetzt bald damit die scheiße
hier runter dass das hier ein bisschen
wenn nicht wird er warum brennt unser
kaktus jetzt überfällig
das ist auf jeden fall dieser keks thema
gott gemacht haben okay kommt den kunden
und den tee habe ich dennoch schon
gegeben vom alter dann kriegt er
festhalten 9 tv du ne vornherein und
jetzt und hier herzlichen glückwunsch
herr du schon wieder dahin
ihr alltag kannst du noch das essen und
appetit auf ein neues lieblingsspiel
an der stelle wird das heutige wieder
ist allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde aber es tut mir leid dass die
komplette tonqualität bescheuert war und
ich auch aber teilweise einfach
irgendwie hier stand aber das ist halt
der nachteil wer diesem virtual reality
krams sender ich allerdings dieser job
simuliert er hier mit mir gefallen hat
dann das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video media und schreibt mir
auch mal unten in die kommentare
ob ich eventuell demnächst mal den
urlaub simulator spielen soll also dass
es quasi genau das gleiche nur dass man
nicht arbeitet sondern im urlaub ist
abonniert main kanal falls sie noch kein
teil der luxus sei das ist kostenlos und
dadurch verpasste keine videos mehr und
wenn ihr schon aber noch zeit dann
klickt gern auf die glocke dann werdet
ihr direkt benachrichtigt sobald ich ein
neues video hochladen übrigens gerade
auch lars rother auf instagram
hochgeladen von mir und meinem hobby
hier habe also geht ja auf meinem profil
laser luca und wenn ihr das gerade sich
dann kommentiert mal mülltonne
ja
[Musik]